filmado discretamente desde un vehículo
la policía antidisturbios armada y con
ropa protectora se despliega en las
calles de jacks en el centro de Irán
aquí no se toleran las manifestaciones
pero desde el 16 de septiembre las
mujeres son las protagonistas de
protestas anti gubernamentales en las
que denuncian no solo la muerte de
marsha Mini sino también la estructura
conservadora de Irán esto cuando el
presidente ultraconservador del país
condenó las manifestaciones el miércoles
la seguridad de las personas es la línea
Roja de la República islámica de Irán y
nadie puede violar la ley y provocar el
caos
Irán llevó a cabo el miércoles
mortíferos ataques transfronterizos en
el norte de Irak dirigidos a las sedes
de tres partidos de la oposición kurda
iraní que apoyan las manifestaciones en
curso dentro de Irán como saben las
protestas que se iniciaron en Irán
proceden del kurdistán o en el kurdistán
donde cobraron impulso y luego se
extendieron por todo Irán y por eso
consideran que nosotros y los partidos
kurdos estamos detrás de estas protestas
el partido democrático kurdo de Irán
confirmó la muerte de dos de sus
miembros y se informó de que decenas de
personas habían muerto resultado heridas
en los ataques según el Ministerio de
sanidad de la región del kurdistán
Washington condena los ataques
calificándolos de ataque descarado a la
soberanía de ira